ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋
สวัสดีค่ะครูเรียมสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
โรงเรียนคะตอนนี้
วัน
ตอนนี้เวลาก่อนก็ได้ค่ะเวลากี่โมงคะตอน
นี้
11:00 น 47 นาทีค่ะ
11 โมง 47 นาทีนวันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้
วันอังคารค่ะวันอังคารวันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 24
วันที่ 20  24 เดือนเดือนอะไรคะเดือน
พฤษภาคม
มีผชอะไรคะพี่พ.ศ
ปีคศอะไรคะปีคศ
2000  22 ค่ะ
ปีพ.ศ 2565 ปีค.ศ 2002  2 คู่เรียมคุยนี้
คำถามถาม
อะไร
จริงๆไม่ควรถามแวะไม่เป็นไรคนไทยถามได้โพ
เรียมแต่งงานหรือยังแต่แอนแป๊บนึงๆๆๆ
ยังค่ะเก๋ยังไม่แต่งงาน
ยังไม่แต่งงานนะคะ
ตัวเองคะตัวเองยังไม่เป็นงานทำไมมีแหวน
แรกนี้
คุณจะไปใส่แหวน
แต่งงานหรือยังคะตื่นเอสจะแต่งงานแล้ว
แต่งงานแล้วค่ะนักเรียนแต่ว่า
วันนี้นะ
มีสามีซึ่งสาวมีตัวเอกเป็นภรรยามีสามีวัน
นี้นะ
โหลดสามีนิดหน่อยหมู่นิดหน่อยจริงๆหรอคะ
พี่เอ๋นิดหน่อยนิดหน่อยก็วันนี้ครูเอ๋ทำ
อาหาร 2 จานเป็นสลับสลัดจันทร์ใหญ่แล้วก็
สลัดจันทร์เล่น
สาวอีควย Android ตื่นแล้วก็ล้างหน้ากู
เอกก็เข้ามามีคลาสชายก็สอนสอนเสร็จกูเอง
ก็ออกไป
สลัดคู่เอ๋อยู่ที่ไหน
สาวอีก้อกำลังกินสลัดแล้วครูเอกก็เห็นอ้ะ
สลัดจันทร์เล็ก
ทั้งหมดแล้ว
สลัดจานใหญ่เหรอคะ
จะมีกำลังกินอยู่เนี่ย
กูเอกก็ถามว่า
สวัสดิ์เอ๋อยู่ที่ไหน
ตกใจเฮ้ย
ผมคิดเหงมีสลัดให้ผม 2 จา
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
ขอโทษนะไม่สุภาพ
ใครจะทำสลัดให้ 2 จาน
สลัดอันหนึ่งจานแล้วก็อย่างอื่นต่อพี่คุย
บอกก็สงสัยวันนี้ทำไมมีสลัด 2 จาน
หิวหรือเปล่าหิวมากๆ
ไม่ได้หิวมากๆหรอกแต่ว่าสามีกูเห็นมีถาด
ใช่ไหมมีเป็นเป็นคนญี่ปุ่นเวลามีขนาดกับ
ต้องมีถาดแล้วก็วางกวางๆเป็นเซ็ตเม็ดใช่
คู๋แล้วเอาของกูเองไปวางในเซตของสามีสามี
ก็ได้ทำไมวันนี้ให้ตลาดมากๆสามีก็เข้าใจ
ว่าอ๋อ 2 จานจานเล็กจานใหญ่เป็นหนึ่ง Dead
กินกินตื่นซิ
ไม่เป็นไรทำไม
เวรกี่ถ้าคนไทยแต่งงานกับคนไทยเข้าใจง่าย
ๆคนไทยแต่งงานกับคนต่างประเทศ
อันนี้อะไรอันนี้อะไรก็จะเข้าใจผิดบ่อยๆ
มีไหมนักเรียนแต่งงานกับคนไทยแล้วอะไร
สามีกูเอกก็ปวดหัวอะไร
ปวดหัวปวดหัวอะไรอ่ะจะทำอะไรนิดนึง
นิดนึงนะสามีเข้าใจผิดก็กูเองเข้าใจผิด
บ่อยๆค่ะ
เพราะว่านก
เขาอย่างคนไทยใช่ไหมคนไทยนักเรียนคนไทย
เวลาเวลากินข้าวก็จะมีมีอ่านี่ต้มยำกุ้ง
อ่ะมีมีอะไรร้านแกงเขียวหวานมีมัสมั่นที่
นี่แล้วก็แบ่งกันแต่ว่าถ้าเป็นญี่ปุ่นเขา
จะต้องเป็นเซต
เซตของเขาเซ็ตของเอ๋อย่างเงี้ยมีถ้าเกิด
วางอยู่ข้างหน้าทุกอย่างทำใหญ่ๆครูเอ๋ยัง
ทำงานออกไปสามีเพื่อนทำหน้าอย่างเงี้ยะ
ทำไมเยอะแล้วก็ต้องไม่ยำกินแล้วต้องกิน
ให้หมดแล้วเขาก็จะหน้าแบบนี้เยอะจังอ่ะ
ถ้าเกิดก็จะพูดทำไมเยอะๆบ่แบ่งกัน
เพราะว่าเธออยู่ในถาดแปลว่าของเขาคนเดียว
ตั้งแต่เด็กๆจนโตอายุ 44 ก็คิดแบบนี้ใช่
ไหม
จะเปลี่ยนเพราะยากราคา 5
กระโดดนิดหน่อยกับไม่เป็นไร
วันนี้ว่าแต่งงานหรือยังจะพาโคเรียมไปดู
การแต่งงาน
ข้างไหนคะพี่เอ๋า
ที่ประเทศไทยแต่ไม่ใช่งานแต่งงานครูเอ๋นะ
ต้องบอกนักเรียนนะคะแต่งงานนะคะก่อนจะไป
งานแต่งงานเนี่ยต้องขุดจะพา Korea มาดู
อันนี้ก่อน
นี่อ่ะ
มีอะไรคะของเอ๋
ดูต้นไม้
ปุ๊บ
ค่าไปดูต้นไม้แต่ที่ต้นอะไรผู้เดียวอีก
แม็กซ์มีชุดไทย
ใช่ค่ะเห็นค่ะกูเอง
ไข่นี่ค่ะมีชุดไทยๆนะคะ
นักเรียนบอกแขวนแขวนแขวนอยู่บนต้นไม้
ใช่เวลาเวลาที่ที่ผู้หญิงไทยแต่งงานก็บาง
คนก็ใส่ชุดไทยเนาะชุดสวยๆแบบนี้เวลาแต่ง
งานนะคะที่นี่เนี่ยวันนี้ที่จะพาไปงาน
แต่งงานเนี่ยเคคือเราเที่ยวว่าที่ต้นไม้
น่ะเรียมต้นไม้นะมีต้นไม้ใหญ่ๆนะคะค่ะที่
ประเทศต้นไม้ใหญ่ๆๆ
ต้นไม้ใหญ่ๆเราก็มีค่า
มีมีอันนี้ค่ะ
เอกแป๊บนึงนะคะเอาไปข้างหลังก่อนอ่ะมี
มีนางไม้
ไม้นะคะไม่ใช่ผีไม่ใช่ผีธรรมดาเรียกว่า
นางมายคนไทยเชื่อมีคนไทยหลายๆที่ที่เชื่อ
ว่าที่ต้นไม้ใหญ่จะมีนางไม้ถ้าเป็นผู้
หญิงถ้าเป็นผู้ชายเค้าเป็นผู้ชายมันจะ
เรียกว่าอะไร
เลี้ยงต่อเล็กลูกค่ะเทวดา
สีแดง
สีชมพูแล้วกันนะถ้าเป็นผู้ชาย
อยู่ที่ต้นไม้เรียกว่าลูกค่ะเทวดาอะ We
Have ก็ 7 นางไม้หรือลูกค่ะเทวดา
อยู่ที่ต้นไม้บางต้นก็เป็นนางไม้บางต้นก็
เป็นลูกค้าเทวดาและเป็นความเชื่อของคนไทย
นะคะแล้วก็จะรู้ได้ยังไงว่าต้นไม้ต้นไหน
มีนางไม้หรือมีลูกผักเทวดาเขาบอกว่าได้
ยินนะเอไม่รู้จริงหรือไม่จริงเขาบอกว่า
ถ้าเอามีด
มีดน่ะแล้วก็ฟันที่ต้นไม้อ่ะถ้าฝันแล้วมี
ยางจะมี
อีกไหลออกมาแบบเนี้ย
บางคนก็บอกออกสีแดงๆ
สีแดงๆแดงๆเป็นนางไม้หรือว่าลุคค่ะค่ะ
เทวดาอะว่าพวกนางมายด์นั้นอาหารนางไม้นะ
คะหรือบางคนเนี่ยเจ้าแม่ก็ได้ผู้ชายก็
เจ้าพ่อค่ะมินิหลายอย่างที่เค้าพูดกัน
เจ้าพ่อลูกขัดเทวดาและเจ้าพ่อก็จะเลเวล
นี้ถ้าลูกขับเทวดาจะเป็นเทวดาแต่ว่านาง
ไม้หรือเจ้าแม่ก็จะมีน้ำเป็นเป็นใครๆสี
แดงๆเหมือนเลือดไหลออกมาคู่เก๋ไม่เคยเห็น
ได้ยินได้ยินไม่รู้ว่าจริงหรือไม่จริงแต่
มบ้านคนไทยเมื่อก่อนน่ะกูเรียมเขาจะต้อง
เอาเอาต้นไม้นะมาทำบ้านใช่ป่ะทำเป็นบ้าน
ยังงั้นเนี่ยท่าเอาต้นไม้มาแล้วต้นไม้ตาย
แล้วแต่ยังมียังมียางไหล
ใช่แล้วก็น่ารักนี้ก็คิดว่ายังไงคะโอเค
ล่าง
วัน
ไหว้ครูเอกเคยเห็นนะเค้าเรียกว่ามีมียาง
ยังมีน้ำมันคือเล่นน้ำมันไหลออกมาตลอด
เวลาจับมันอันนี้ต้องไหว้นะคะแต่ว่ามีนาง
ไม้หรือมีผีจะผู้ชายก็ได้ผู้หญิงก็ได้
อยู่ข้างใน
ซึ่งซึ่งถ้าจะรู้คือบางคนเขาก็จะเห็นจะ
เห็นว่าอยู่ข้างในในนี้
อะไรต้นไม้อาจ
จะเนี่ยเวลาเวลาจะตัดต้นไม้น่ะก็ต้องไหว้
ต้นไม้ก่อนขอขอว่าชมทุกครูเรียมอยากได้
ต้นไม้ตอนนี้อยากได้ต้นไม้ต้นนี้ผู้เรียน
ก็ต้องไหว้ราคาแล้วก็บอกว่านางไม้ขอต้น
ไม้ตอนนี้นะนางไม้ไปอยู่ต้นอื่นขอ
ให้นางไม้นะ
มีทั้งไม้ย้ายย้ายออกไปแล้วค่อยตัด
เตรียมไม่ขออ่ะเอาลูกค้าเทวดาออกไปด้วย
อ่ะออกไปก่อนออกไปอ่ะให้ออกไปนะคะเท่า
ออกไปออกไปให้หมดอ่ะถ้าไม่ขอล่ะคะไม่ขอ
อยากได้ต้นไม้ต้องนี้เรายังเป็นตัดอะเลย
บางทีถ้าตัดก็ไม่สบายณบุรีเรียม
อาจจะไม่สบายหรือว่าอาจจะตัดไม่ได้อาจจะ
ล้มลงมาทับคนตัดน่ะตายเลยนะหนึ่ง
หรืออาจจะมีต่อมีอะไรมีตัวแมลงมากัดงง
นั้นนะหรือค่าคุณเรียมตัดได้เอามาที่บ้าน
เวลาโคเรียมนอนก็จะเห็นผู้หญิงเดินหรือ
บางที่เสือ
ร้องไห้มาว่ายังนอนแล้วก็
โอเคมั้ยไม่โอเคไม่โอเคค่ะคุณเอ๋แต่ว่า
เราจะรู้ได้ยังไงคะเวลาที่เราไหว้แล้วนาง
ไม้จะย้ายออกไปที่ต้นไม้ต้นอื่น
ก็ไม่รออธิบานนะคะอ่าบ้านไผ่เป็นเสาแบบ
นี้
บ้านส่งไผ่เดี๋ยวนะเตรียมแป๊บนึงถ้าเกิด
อันนี้แล้วครูเรียมถามว่าเราจะรู้ได้ไง
ว่าย้ายไหว้แล้วก็คิดว่ายาย้าย
[เพลง]
ตับเนี่ยเวลาตัดถ้าไม่มีปัญหาก็คือย้าย
นิ้งกัดแล้วมีปัญหาคนไม่สบายปวดท้องมี
อะไรที่เป็นปัญหาตัดไม่ได้แต่ว่านางไม้
ไม่ให้เอา
ไปให้ก็คือต้องเปลี่ยนต้นไม้
[เพลง]
ต้องเปลี่ยนต้นไม้นะคะนั่นเรียนเองเหรอ
เกี่ยวอะไรก็แต่งงานนี่ขณะกำลังจะถามผู้
เองหรือว่า
แต่งงานเกี่ยวอะไรกับต้นไม้
ที่ที่ภาคใต้
ที่ภาคใต้ประเทศไทยเนี่ยอ้ะมี
นินะคะกูเห็นมีต้นมะม่วงนะก็ที่ภาคใต้
เนี่ยเขาบอกว่าเมื่อก่อนเมื่อก่อนอ่ะมี
ต้นมะม่วงมีตอนบักม่วงป่านะคะคู๋นะไม่ไม่
รู้นะคะว่าทำไมอ่ะเขาไม่ได้บอกเขาบอกแค่
ว่ามีต้นมะม่วงมะม่วงแบบนี้ค่ะที่ว่า
มะม่วงกะล่อนภาษาภาษาภาษาบ้านครูเอกเรียก
ว่ามะม่วงกะล่อน
อยู่
ที่บ้านเรียบแบบเหมือนกัน
เปลือกยังเป็นสีเขียวแล้วเนื้อเนี่ยจะ
เป็นสีเหลืองนะคะทำเม็ดน่ะข้างในมีเม็ด
ตรงนี้นักเรียนเม็ดไม่ใหญ่มาก
เม็ดน่ะเนี้ยเม็ดใหญ่เนาะ
ขอมากนะเออเวลาเป็นสีเขียวร้อย
เปอร์เซ็นต์
มากๆกินแล้วเปรี้ยว
ที่นี่แล้วตอนเด็กๆบ้านครูเอ๋ May แปลว่า
โตแล้วไม่มีล่ะเห็นชอบมากอ่ะเขาบอกว่าที่
ภาคใต้มีมุกอ่ะมีมะม่วงต้นมะม่วงป่าอยู่
ต้นเลยต้นใหญ่มากนะคะเป็นมะม่วงกะล่อนใน
คนอื่นในรูปมะม่วงกะล่อนให้ดู
LOVE มะม่วงเข้าในมะม่วงเหรอคะคุณเอ๋ค่ะ
นี่เป็นข้าวเหนียวมะม่วงได้
หรือว่ากินแบบนี้ก็ได้โอ๊ยหิว
5 เห็นแล้วหิวมา
เครียดอย่างนี้ครูเรียมเขาบอกว่าที่มาต้น
มะม่วงกะล่อนเนี่ยก็มีเหมือนเป็นนางไม้
และนั้นไม้คู่เอกก็ไม่รู้ที่มาที่ไปยังไง
แต่ว่าเขาบอกว่าผู้ชายที่เนี่ยที่จังหวัด
สงขลา
ภาคใต้รหัสที่ขาอาจมีอยู่มีอยู่จังหวัด
หนึ่งชื่อสงขลา
ผู้ชายนักเป็นเป็นที่หมู่บ้านนี้เลยนะคะ
ขายเวียนมันจะไปไหนเองบ้านให้ด่วนเป็น
คุยหรือว่าแผนที่สงคราม
เย็นอยากส่งไปให้กูเอ๋อ่ะ
ก็
ได้ๆๆส่งมาได้ค่ะอาจเป็นจังหวัดแล้วก็
อำเภอจะแวะอำเภอแล้วก็ในอำเภอก็มีหมูมี
ตำบลนะคะแล้วก็มีหมู่บ้านอ่ะกอล์ฟหมู่
บ้านไปคือมีบ้านบ้านบ้านกูเอกก็จำไม่ได้
ชื่อหมู่บ้านอร่อยนะคะก็มิดมีหมู่บ้านนึง
ราคามีหมู่บ้านหนึ่งเขาก็
เวลาจะแต่งงานเวลาผู้ชายผู้ชายสมมุติผู้
ชายคิดจะแต่งงานอ่ะก่อนก่อนแต่งงานจริงๆ
อ่ะก็ต้องแต่งงานกับ
ต้นมะม่วงก่อน
แต่งงานกับแป้งต้นมะม่วง
เมื่อเขามีต้นมะม่วงใหญ่จำเป็นเป็นเรื่อง
เล่ามาก่อนมาก็จะมีต้นมะม่วงใหญ่อยู่ต้น
หนึ่งเป็นมะม่วงกะล่อนทองเนี่ยเขาเรียก
มะม่วงแต่แล้วเขาเชื่อว่าที่ต้นมะม่วง
เนี่ยมีนางไม้
ด่างไม้
นางไม้ชื่อ
เจ้าแม่
ม่วงทองมั้งเจ้าแม่มูลท้องนะคะมีหักก็รูป
นี้นะคะคุยเรื่องซื้อผิดนี้จะโดน
ทำไมต้องไปแต่งงานกับต้นไม้ล่ะคะพระเอก
ไม่แต่งงานกับผู้หญิง
อ้อเป็นประเพณีที่นั่นก่อนแต่งงานกับผู้
หญิง
ก่อนแต่งงานกับผู้หญิงเขาจะต้องแต่งงาน
กับอ่ะต้นไม้รับขึ้นแต่งงานกับนางไม้อ่ะ
ค่ะเขาได้แต่งงานกับนางไม้อ่ะแต่งงานกับ
นางไม้เสร็จแล้วไปเป็นพระโอเค
คะแล้วก็ไปไปแต่งงานกับผู้หญิงโอเคต้อง
แต่งงานกับนางไม้คิดเจ้าแม่ม่วงทองเนี่ย
ก็คือคนนี้นะค่ะคนนี้เขาเรียกเจ้าแม่ม่วง
ท้อง
ทุกๆคนที่อยู่ในหมู่บ้านไหมคะพี่ต้องไป
แต่งงาน
เป็นความเชื่อก็อาจจะไม่ทุกคนนะคะที่จะ
ที่จะไปแต่งงานคืออันนี้สมมติว่าอันนี้
เป็นครอบครัว
มีผู้ชายคนเนี้ย
ผู้ชายคนนี้ใช่ไหมคะก่อนจะแต่งงานเค้า
ต้องแต่งงานกับนางไม้
แต่งงานกับนางไม้
แล้วก็เวลาเค้าแต่งงานเสร็จเขาก็มีลูกชาย
ลูกชาย
ลูกสาวลูกชายก็ลูกชายคนเนี้ยก็
ต้องแต่งงานกับนางไม้ลูกชายคนโต
ลูกชายคนโตจะแต่งงานกับนางไม้แต่ว่าลูก
ชายคนเล็กๆไม่ต้องแต่งงานกับนานๆมี
คุยไม่ไม่แน่ใจว่าทำไมอาจจะเคยมีผู้ชาย
แล้วก็ไปเจอผู้ชายไปเจอกับนางไม้แล้วก็
สองคนรักกัน
รักกันแต่ว่าอยู่ด้วยกันน่ะไม่ได้เพราะ
ว่านางไม้มันเหมือนเป็นผีเนาะอ่ะก็เลย
ต้องมีประเพณีว่าแต่งงานกับนางไม้ก่อนที่
จะไปแต่งงานกับคน
แต่งงานกับนางน้ายดีหรือไม่ดีคะตัวเอกดี
โชคดีผู้โชคดีนะคะเวลาเขามีชุดแต่งงานนะ
คะครูเรียมเวลาแต่งงานกับนางไม้เนี่ยผู้
ชายจะใส่เสื้อสีขาวแล้วก็จงกระเบนสีอะไร
ก็ได้แล้วก็ต้องมีคนและคนทำพิธีในพิธี
แต่งงานกับนางมาหมายหรือใส่ชุดนี้ก็ได้
ค่ะอ่ะชุดนี้ชุดเป็นเสื้อตัวนี้เรียกว่า
เสื้อราชประแตนแล้วก็จงกระเบนเราก็
Love  Bay ถุงเท้าสีขาวรองเท้าสีดำ
แล้วก็ตอนที่อยู่
อะไรนะคะที่เห็นข้างๆคืออะไรคะคุณเอ๋นะคะ
อันนี้เรียกว่า
อันนี้เรียกว่ากริชราคา
กริชเนี่ยจะต้องอยู่ที่เองม
6  Grid ที่เอวด้วย
นะค่ะ
ที่เอวไว้ที่เอวแล้วก็เขาก็ไปแต่งงานกับ
นางไม้คอแต่งงานกับนางไม้เสร็จแล้วเนี่ย
อาจจะ 1 วัน 2 วัน 3 วันก็ค่อยไปแต่งงาน
กับผู้หญิงขอ
ทำไมใช่มั้ยใช่ทำไมต้องแต่งงานทั้งที่ 1
แต่งงานครั้งที่สอง
เออ
จริงๆนะกูเอกไปอ่านมานะคะเขาก็บอกว่า
เนื่องจากภาคใต้น่ะปิดคนไทยแล้วก็คนไทย
มุสลิม
คนไทยก็มีวัฒนธรรมไทย
คนอ้วน Slim ก็มีวัฒนธรรมมุสลิมแบบผู้
หญิงมุสลิมสวย
สวยมากมาแล้วถ้าคนไทยอยากจะแต่งงานกับ
มุสลิม
จัดทำอะไรดีจะแต่งงานแบบถ่ายมีพระหรือ
แต่งงานแบบมุสลิมฆ่าแต่งงานแบบมุสลิมพ่อ
แม่ไทยก็โออาจจะไม่สบายใจอาบท่าแต่งงาน
แบบไทยพ่อแม่ผู้หญิงก็ไม่สบายใจเขาบอกว่า
เป็นเช็คบิดคนโบราณโบราณพอมาแต่งงานกับ
นางไม้ก่อนเนี่ยก็คือเอาไทยกับมุสลิมมา
รวมกัน
เนี่ยชุดนะถ่ายแต่กริชในเป็นแบบมุสลิม
[เพลง]
อันนี้เป็นแบบมุสลิมนะคะเป็นแบบมุสลิม
แพ่งใต้อ่ะค่ะเป็นแบบ r-mar เรยค่ะคล้ายๆ
มาเลย์มารวมๆนะถ้าคุณเรียมเห็นในนี้ก็จะ
เห็นว่าตรงนี้ถ่ายเป็นคนเนี้ยอ่ะก็เป็นสี
ค่าเป็นมุสลิม
เมื่อชายไทยกับหญิงมุสลิมชอบกัน
งั้นเขาก็เลยเป็นเทคนิคมั้งแต่แต่ว่าอัน
นี้คนคนที่เป็นคนเขียนเค้าเรียกอะไรทำ
แล้วก็คิดเอ๊ะทำไมทำไมเขาบอกว่านี้แต่ว่า
ถ้าเป็นคนประจำภาคเขาเชื่อว่าต้องแต่งกับ
นางไม้จริงๆแล้วค่อยแต่งกับคนอันเนี้ยจะ
โชคดี
เป็นเรื่องของโชคดีคู่เอกก็กู a นะเคยได้
ยินมาบ่อยๆว่ามีนางไม้ที่ต้นไม้นะถ้าๆหาย
เรียนก็ได้ยินบ่อยๆแต่เพิ่งได้ยินวัดแต่ง
งานกับต้นไม้จากครู a ให้เรามา
เอกกำลังอยากจะสอนนั่นแหละเรื่องนางไม้จะ
มาว่าคนตัวปั๊มเชื่อเรื่องนางไม้แต่ไปดู
มีแต่งงานกับรางไม้แต่คู๋แต่งงานกับคนทาย
ผู้ชายไม่ใช่ผู้ชายๆ
มาก็เลยจะแต่งมันหลังไม้น่าจะดีนางไม้น่า
จะพูดนิดหน่อยนะ
ๆก็เลยเขาก็มีมีตรงนี้เขาเรียกว่าศาลเจ้า
แม่ม่วงทอง
คือมาก่อนมีต้นมะม่วงใหญ่ๆราคาก็จะลงคิด
ต้องมะม่วงเลยแปะต้นมะม่วงเนี่ยนานแล้วก็
มีฟ้าผ่าแล้วก็ตายเขาก็เปลี่ยนเป็นต้นไม้
อื่นเขาก็เลยทำสั่งศาลศาลแบบนี้ค่ะก็เลย
ให้นางไม้มาอยู่ที่ศาล
ชายแล้วก็มีต้นไม้ตรงนี้คนอื่นๆถ้ามีต้น
ไม้ข้างหลัง
เปลี่ยนต้นไม้ใหม่ให้ประเพณีนี้ก็ยังอยู่
นะคะมีอยู่ให้ผู้ชายไปก็แต่งงานกับนางไม้
ก่อนแต่งงานจริงนะฮะหรือก่อนมันเป็นพระ
อ่าหมายก่อนลืมพ่อแม่จะได้ไทยก็สบายใจพ่อ
แม่ฝ่ายมุสลิมก็สบายใจอ่าเพราะว่าเอา 2
อย่างมารวมกันแล้วมารวมกันแล้วก็แต่งงาน
เข้ามาทักผู้ชายผู้ชายไทยเวลาไปแต่งงาน
กับมุสลิม
จะต้องมี 1  2  3 ทำอะไรใช่ไหมใช่ครับ
เพิ่งๆบางคนก็รู้สึกตื่นเต้นตื่นเต้นนิด
หน่อยนะคะโอน่าสนใจเนาะเรื่องนางไม้เนี่ย
นักเรียน
ตอนเด็กๆนะครูเรียมครูเอกคิดว่านางสุด
ท้ายมีจริงๆมีจริงๆนะคะแล้วพอโตโตๆขึ้นมา
คู่เอกก็คิดเองมีไม่มีจริงไม่จริงกูเอกก็
อยู่กรุงเทพฯก็บ้านไม่ใช่หมายสบายใจใช่
ไหมไม่ไม่ต้องมีผู้หญิงเดินไปเดินมารับ
นี้
ไปเดินมาในบ้าน
เราคิดอยู่ที่บ้านน่ะครูเอ๋เป็นผู้หญิงคน
เดียวแต่ว่าถ้าหันไปเอาผู้หญิงที่ไหนว่า
เดินแล้วก็หายไป
โอ้ยกูเอกเคยเห็นเคยอยู่อยู่คอนโดที่
คอนโดไม่ใช่ที่เนี่ยกูเรียมคอนโดที่มีต้น
ไม้ใหญ่มากต้นไม้สูงสูงเท่ากับมีกี่ชั้น
ค่ะประม่ณ
1  2  3  4  5  5  6
7  8 แล้วต้นไม้เนี่ยที่นี่เลย
[เพลง]
ต้นไม้สูงเท่ากับ 8 ชั้นมากแล้วก็ห้องที่
ครูเอ๋อยู่นะชั้นที่ 1 เป็นไม้ที่ห้องมี
ไม้คู๋เคยเห็นผู้หญิงเดินในห้องผู้หญิง
เดิน
ผู้หญิงนั่งนั่งที่เตียงนอนผู้ป่วยอ่ะกู
เรียมเตียงนอนก็เป็นไม้แล้วก็ผู้หญิงนั่ง
แล้วก็หันมานักเนี่ยผมยาวเหมือนคุยจะมา
แล้วก็คู๋เดินออกจากไปอาบน้ำอาบน้ำเสร็จ
เดินออกมาหันไปเห็นผู้หญิงคุณเรียมหันได้
ข้างๆ
อย่าหันไปข้างๆแล้วก็หันมามองมองกล้อง
หันหนูอยากคุยตกใจ
นุ้ย
หรือเปล่า
แล้วก็เปิดประตูเข้ามานั่งรอกูเอ๋
อยู่กันสองคนครูเอกกับสาวอีคุยก็ตกใจให้
แล้วก็หายไปเลย
ครูเอกอะไรเอกก็โอเคสามีเปลี่ยน
เปลี่ยนคอนโด
เปลี่ยนคันโดไม่ได้ซื้อใช่ไหมเท่าเท่า
จ่ายเงินทุกเดือนสามีบอกไม่ซื้อเพราะว่า
อ่ะเท่าถ้าไม่ดีเปลี่ยนได้ก็เปลี่ยนนะ
เปลี่ยนที่นี่โอ้สบายใจเพราะว่าเป็นปูนนะ
คะถ้าไม่มีไม้มีต้นไม้นิดหน่อยนะคะหากคู่
เอกก็ได้คิดเองนางไม้เนี่ย
จริงหรือไม่จริงก็เลยไปหาดูก็มีคนเชื่อ
เรื่องนางไม้มากๆเหมือนกันนะ
ใช่เรียมเชื่อไหมคะคุณเรียมเชื่อว่า
เตรียมคิดว่าไม่รู้แต่ว่าก็ไม่ได้ไปทำ
อะไรนางไม้นะคะค่ะไม่รู้แต่ก็ไม่ไม่ยุ่ง
ไม่ได้ไหว้แต่ก็เดินเดินผ่านไปเฉยๆไม่ได้
ทำอะไร
คู๋เวลาเห็นปิดจะเดินไกลๆ
กลัวว่าเดินใกล้ๆเดี๋ยวเป็นผลนางไม้ก็
เดินไกลๆนะบางคนก็เรียกว่านะคะบางคนก็บอก
ว่าผีบางคนก็เรียกเจ้าแม่
นี้นะครับบางคนก็บอกนางไม้นะคะนางบายก็
เป็นที่เราไม่รู้มองไม่เห็นหน้าไส้บางคน
ก็เห็นค่านักเรียนมาเมืองไทยแล้วก็เห็น
ต้นไม้แล้วก็มีผ้าผูกอาจจะนางไม้ลูกค้า
เทวดาเจ้าพ่อเจ้าแม่
รู้ได้ยังไงผู้หญิงผู้ชายดูค่ะถ้ามีเสื้อ
ผ้าผู้หญิงต้องผู้หญิงถ้าไม่มีเสื้อผ้าก็
ก็อาจจะไม่เช้าผู้หญิงน่าจะผู้ชายนะคะ
โอเคโอเควันนี้ก็พานักเรียนไปดูการแต่ง
งานกับตำนานไม้
รู้จักทางมา
[เพลง]
ที่หมู่บ้านดรีมนะคะที่สงขลาที่เดียวนะคะ
เป็นเป็นหมู่บ้านหนึ่งหมู่บ้านขอราคาใช่
โอเคค่ะพรุ่งนี้เราไปต่อนะคะได้ทั้งหมด
ใจกันคลิปหน้าค่ะสวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋
สวัสดีค่ะบ๊ายบายสวัสดีค่ะนะพี่ไม่มาอ่ะ